PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Deconstructing Chatbots.
I am Priyanka Vergadia,
and in this episode,
we will integrate Dialogflow
with Twilio's messaging
service.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of my friends uses
Twilio messaging service
and requested that I walk
him through setting up
Twilio bots with natural
language understanding
based on Dialogflow.
So here we go.
Again, we are going to work with
the same appointment scheduler
chatbot and integrate it with
Twilio's messaging service
so that our users
who choose to text us
can get the same experience
as the ones who are using us
on web and Google Home.
We are in our agent.
Let's click Integration.
This time we are going to click
on Twilio's text messaging
service.
The pop-up has some
instructions-- click on Start,
copy the request URL, and
put it in the Twilio's
programmable SMS.
There are more instructions;
if you click on the link,
it takes you to the
detailed screenshots
and how to set it up.
But for now, let's
just do it ourselves.
The first thing you will
need is a Twilio account.
If you don't have one,
create it and then log in.
From the dashboard,
click on All the Products
and navigate to
Programmable SMS.
Once you are on the Programmable
SMS dashboard, click on SMS.
I already have an appointment
scheduled a messaging service
set up here, but you can
just create one for yourself,
provide it a name,
and in the use case,
select Chatbot
Interactive 2-Way.
Let's click on the
messaging service you
created to assign
a phone number.
Use the Add button to
buy a new phone number
or just use an existing
number if you have one.
Click through the US
selections and you
should have a number assigned.
Now we click on
the configuration
to integrate Dialogflow.
Enable inbound settings.
In the request
URL, copy and paste
the URL that was generated by
Dialogflow in the Integration
section and save it.
Now copy the service ID, phone
number, and the auth token
from Twilio dashboard and
paste them in the Dialogflow
Integration Console again.
Once you're done, click
on Save and start.
Yay!
Our bot started successfully.
Now it's time to test your
bot via text messages.
So we will use the
number we assigned
to our messaging service and
run through that example again.
Hi.
I would like to set an
appointment for 3:00
PM tomorrow.
Driver's license.
Great, we received
a confirmation.
All right.
So today we integrated our
appointment scheduler chatbot
with Twilio messaging
service, enabling our users
to set an appointment via text.
We managed to provide
the exact same experience
to our users using our bot
from the website or via text.
Well, that's a win.
That's it for today.
Join me in the next episode
for deconstructing chatbots
where we will learn
more about fulfillments.
If you like this video
and want to see more,
subscribe to our channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]